journée décisive demain pour christine
villemin inculpée de l'assassinât de son
fils est emprisonné à metz la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de nancy
examinera la demande de mise en liberté
provisoire déposée par la mère de
grégory est rejetée par le juge lambert
les magistrats de nancy se pencheront
avec beaucoup d'attention sur l'emploi
du temps de christine villemin
alors du meurtre le 16 octobre 80 cas
tout c'est peut-être joué en moins de 20
minutes c'est ce que pense le juge
lambert mais l'avocat de christine
villemin rejette ce soupçon impossible
dit-il de croire que la mère de grégory
a pu faire disparaître son enfant en un
laps de temps aussi court
ces 20 minutes sont donc déterminante
marcel trillât et thierry mais n'y ont
tenté de les reconstituer festive
villemin quitte son travail au centre de
l'évangile et 16h56 le 16 octobre 1984
dans quelques minutes son fils grégory
va mourir
les camarades de travail affirme l'avoir
vu poster une lettre à l'heure où le
corbeau expédié la sienne annonçant
l'assassinât de l'enfant
elle prétend être allé directement
vendre son fils chez la nourrice avant
de remonter chez elle et dernier à
l'avoir vue monsieur colin et madame
quand didier
ils bavardent est ici en haut du village
une voiture passe de tinghir montait
dans sa voiture
deux parties madame d'une main au monde
mais là je ne fais pas dire si son petit
garçon était avec elle c'est quand je
suis rentré à ma cuisine il était 5
heures vous êtes entré tout de suite
après 2,3 me et vous avez regardé
l'heure oui parce que j'avais un 50
mètres plus haut un croisement pour
christine villemin aucun doute elle a
pris à droite vers chez elle peu après
17 heures elle s'enferme pour repasser
l'enfant joue dans la cour la voiture
est dans le garage sans porte à droite
de la maison
pourtant quelques minutes plus tard
monsieur colin longe la villa sans
remarquer ni l'enfant ni la voiture
alors christine villemin at elle menti
en haut du village at elle tourné à
gauche vers d'eau sel ou grégory est
mort nous avons chronométré à plusieurs
reprises le trajet les poches d'eau sel
sur cette route étroite et tortueuse où
personne ne l'a aperçu ce jour-là une
route souvent encombrée par les
tracteurs et les troupeaux au bout de la
route le village de dos elle que
christine aurait traversé presque de
part en part
à l'heure de sortie d'une usine de 250
ouvriers près de l'église
elle aurait ligoter l'enfant puis
l'aurait jetée dans la vologne
derrière le bâtiment des sapeurs
pompiers d'après les simulations faites
à l'aide de mannequins
c'est ici en effet que l'enfant a dû
être noyé pour que son corps ait pu
dériver jusqu'au barrage en contrebas où
ans l'a repêché il faisait beau ce jour
là les habitants de dos elle profiter
des derniers rayons de soleil d'octobre
personne n'a vu l'horrible scène en
plein jour en plein village compte tenu
du temps nécessaire pour ligoter
l'enfant trois minutes d'après les
enquêteurs il aurait fallu en tout plus
de 19 minutes à christine villemin
pour faire l'aller-retour à un train
d'enfer sans hésitation ni incident de
parcours et tout cela avec une petite
voiture en très mauvais état
elle a été vue pour la dernière fois on
s'en souvient près de cet embranchement
environ deux minutes avant 17 heures 19
minutes plus tard le temps minimum du
trajet à 17h17 madame claudon et son
mari viennent chercher leurs troupeaux
juste au dessous de la maison des villes
mhz tandis que monsieur claude on barre
la route avec sa voiture
madame claudon
placez une barrière devant chez les
villemin où elle ne voit personne
puis elle redescend faire sortir les
vaches de son prêt et les pousser vers
la route vers 17h20 elle passe pour la
seconde fois devant la maison des villes
et puis j'ai reparti avec le trophée
alors elle m'a demandé si j'avais vu
grégory j'ai dit non ils étaient deux
mois à peu près parce que j'étais chez
nous j'ai dit à mon mari
il est sain que records vous avez pas
été chercher les vaches parce que
j'étais encore d'habitude je viens
toujours à ça que christine villemin ne
pouvait pas prévoir le retard de madame
claude non au retour de de sel elle
risquait de se trouver nez à nez avec
elle et elle le savait dans l'hypothèse
où elle est coupable et seul coupable
elle a bénéficié pour parcourir le
trajet dans les temps et commettre son
crime sans être vue d'une chance
diabolique
elle a fait preuve d'une détermination
et d'un sang froid digne d'une
criminelle d'exception une thèse qui
aurait bien besoin de preuves décisives
ou d'aveux pour devenir irréfutables et
pour dissiper vraiment le mystère de la
mort du petit grégory